dans football et de deux pour le psg les
parisiens ont remporté leur deuxième
titre de champion de france la première
fois c'était il ya huit ans en 86 hier
soir les hommes d'artur jorge ont battu
toulouse au parc des princes a à 0 un
but libérateur de ricardo dénis ferney
et denis boucher ça y est ils sont
champions supporters et joueurs peuvent
exulter
je crois qu'on a bien travaillé de
trajan ici on a on apparaît aussitôt
bien sûr ces personnes au monde
on a bien une ambiance qu'on a bien
travaillé dans trois ans ces recrues
championnat c'est qu'elle est
l'aboutissement d'une superbe saison
même s'il n'a pas été exceptionnel par
moments c'est vrai que c'est les plus
réguliers qui sont au bout et je crois
que c'est le grand mérite qu'on peut
avoir pour moi qui suis un passionné de
football je le retrouvais ce soir une
émotion et une grande joie c'est très
très content cette 36e journée aura donc
été la bonne pour le psg face à toulouse
même si l'on fait le minimum ici un tir
de fourni au dessus les parisiens vont
s'imposer portant leur avance au
classement à sept points sur l'ol une
reprise de roche sur corner s'écrase sur
le poteau de casanova et enfin sur un
corner de valdo ricardo de la tête
catapulte le ballon au fond des filets
toulousains
un but synonyme de victoire et de titre
pour le psg un pari ça crée un paris
libéré après les éliminations en coupe
de france et d'europe
enfin un peu de joie pour le paris
saint-germain ricardo valdo la précieuse
paire brésilienne a encore frappé
mettant du baume au coeur des supporters
un tir de loin de cole terre est tout
près de faire mouche mais les hommes
d'artur jorge vont malgré tout être à la
peine et ne parviendront pas à aggraver
la marque
malgré une tête de weah qui passe juste
à côté c'est fini et tandis que retentit
l'hymne de des queen we are the
champions des milliers de supporters
parisiens se précipite sur la pelouse à
la rencontre de leur idole pour un
instant de bonheur